plenty of great Sunday night football
games in 2020 every game is a great game
I defy you big cat to look at that
schedule and find a single game where
you say I'll pass
they are great from the beginning to the
end we have the traditional kickoff game
on Thursday night September 10 playoff
rematch we talked about that earlier
Texans and the Chiefs cowboys and Rams
open the new stadium in LA week one and
then how about I mean we don't even
waste any time to get to the Super Bowl
xlix rematch the teams that only play
each other once every four years the
last time they played was a Sunday night
Patriots Seahawks it was in New England
before and now it's in Seattle Packers
Saints week three are you kidding me
Aaron Rodgers and Drew Brees Eagles
49ers week four that should be a great
game because the Eagles are a team that
is much improved over last year and I
can recall some great egos 49ers games
of years past
Vikings Seahawks well you know what that
one's gonna be the Seahawks win 23
nothing so we'll just forget about that
because it's prime time it's Kirk
Cousins in Seattle we know how that goes
Rams 49ers week six another great one
Tom Brady and the Raiders in Las Vegas
week 7 Cowboys Eagles week 8 that's just
the first half of the schedule that
could be the highlights of the schedule
big cat it keeps getting better and
better through the second half and we've
got the Thanksgiving night game as we've
had every year since 2011 I believe
Ravens and the Steelers that's the
reunion of the Thanksgiving night Mike
Tomlin trippin Jacoby Jones game Mike
when can you flex one can NBC start
flexing these schedules because I need
to flex that bears-packers game when can
they start flexing out with week 11 so
you're you're in that you're in the
bubble by the way the one thing that
stands out it's just a pit in my stomach
anytime your team plays on prime-time
television and they might not be a very
good team it always is worrisome how
they're gonna perform but you're right
great schedule I'll give you the only
complaint I have about the schedule and
it will surprise you because that you
think that I'm
going to put my foot in my mouth and do
something that will jeopardize your
relationship with NBC but no I am NOT
all contraire I'm just going to say it's
always weird to see the new rams logo
and they really screwed that up we know
one thing I noticed earlier today on
Twitter they have revised the look of
their field in LA very subtly they took
out that hideous la with the horn logo
and they put in the RAM head instead at
midfield in the mock-ups that are
floating around of what the stadium will
look like very subtle change but they
have heard the people people don't like
that LA logo and maybe it's going to
start to be minimized but hey look and
you know here's the thing going into a
season there is optimism and we know
some of these games will be better than
we expected as we get later into the
season and some will be worse and that
flex option is important to keep in mind
because it continues to give the NFL the
ability to say if the Bears stink come
week 12 if they don't want to subject
this to Nick Foles mich true Biscay Jay
Cutler whoever the quarterback may be
out goes that game and in goes a better
game I mean that's been a fixture now
for so long we kind of take it for
granted but it's it's insurance against
getting to the back end of the season
and having one of these games implode
because of a quarterback injury or just
because one of the teams is 1 in 10 and
that's good that's good
you don't have that on Monday Night
Football and you run the risk of getting
into November in December and you're
like God why am i watching this game
between a couple of teams you just are
irrelevant yeah and the Sunday Night
Football schedule looking this great
right now is so is so great for the
health of the league and I know the NFL
has no problems but it does matter what
games are played in primetime because
when it comes to football when you get
to that red zone Sunday afternoon every
single game can be bad if they're close
and we're watching them all at the same
time it doesn't feel like they're bad
when you have these standalone games
Thursday Sunday Monday and it's bad
quarterback play and and blow outs
that's when you really feel it and
that's when it feels like everyone goes
down on the NFL and says well the
quarterback play
not up to par and and the product isn't
as good so having these standalone games
be high-quality and teams that should
matter come November in December is
super super important and I'm excited
this now has I wasn't as excited when we
started the show I'm now have the juices
falling and that's probably the coffee
but I'll also say it's a Sunday night
football schedule
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports